Zachary Richard bonjour bonjour Merci
d'être ici ça nous fait un grand plaisir
aussi j'ai été bercé depuis quelques
jours il y avait les couleurs de
l'automne il y avait votre musique avec
votre dernière album danser le ciel qui
reprend des très belles chansons
racontez-moi un peu
quel a été l'origine de ce projet-là
vous vouliez refaire des chansons
connues mais différemment j'ai eu un
expérience qui m'a complètement séduit
j'ai chanté avec une symphonie en
Louisiane il y a environ 4 ans un
répertoire qui incluait plusieurs de mes
chansons plus ou moins connues la
réaction du public
le plaisir que j'ai eu à approfondir mon
répertoire m'a séduit complètement ça
fait que de fil en aiguille je suis
arrivé chez les frères Petrowski ici à
Montréal Boris qui a fait les
arrangements Nicolas qui a réalisé
l'album et puis j'ai revisité
effectivement le répertoire mais avec un
nouveau regard ce qui fait que bien que
ce soit les mêmes
mélodies ce sont des nouvelles chansons
en quelque sorte est-ce que c'est le
Zachary Richard plus doux que l'on
entend plus on a l'impression qu'il y a
une douceur là encore plus
je pense pas qu'il y a plusieurs
académies de choses je pense qu'il y a
un il y a des fois qui est plus ou moins
doux et d'autres fois plus ou moins pas
j'en sais rien mais de pouvoir
enregistrer avec un orchestre de chambre
pour moi c'était
très très excitant parce que c'est pas
mon monde moi je viens du folk alors de
pouvoir faire des chansons de Ford dans
un contexte avec 28 musiciens
c'était pour moi
un grand plaisir d'abord on va danser
dans
sous les rayons de la plaine le plus
janvier pas de deux une nouvelle salle
de temps danse le ciel de notre
exaltation
Zachary Richard est comme un ami qu'on a
pas vu depuis longtemps dès les
premières minutes on a l'impression
qu'on s'est vu la veille il n'est pas
d'ici mais depuis les années 70 il n'a
jamais été très loin non plus nous
partageons avec lui une passion commune
la langue française c'est la belle
saison plus de ça chez nous c'est le
printemps quand tous les oiseaux ils
chantent tout le monde est en amour
[Musique]
Louisiane
américain Zachary Richard est né à La
Fayette en 1950 les Richards comme des
milliers de familles acadiennes
déportées se sont installés dans le sud
des États-Unis avec les créoles et les
descendants des colons français entre
autres ils ont formé les francophones de
Louisiane les cageurs
c'est ici m'intéresse ici dans la pauvre
de la fête de la paroisse de
saint-landerie que depuis 200 ans ma
famille était installée
cette morceau de terre ici ça fait à peu
près tout ce temps là que ça appartient
au Richard les grands-parents de Zachary
Richard ne parlaient que le français
ses parents ont été anglicisés de force
il y a 60 ans un million d'Américains
par les Français en Louisiane
aujourd'hui ils sont moins de 200 000
[Musique]
chanter en français pour vous c'est tout
sauf anodin c'est ça a été ça a été la
colonne vertébrale de votre vie
artistique et de ce que vous avez donc
montré au public
50 ans plus tard est-ce que le français
se porte mieux ou se porte plus mal en
Amérique je pense pas que c'est la
question à poser je pense la question
est à poser pour les francophones
militants comme moi en Amérique du Nord
c'est ce qu'on va faire pour pouvoir le
promouvoir c'est sûr que on va jamais
retourner en Louisiane à l'époque de mes
grands-parents là je parle de 1900 quand
même mais 85% des habitants du Sud-Ouest
la Louisiane était parlé une selon le
ressourcement américain une langue
étrangère c'est-à-dire il était
unilingue francophone on va jamais
retrouver ça mais que le français reste
en Louisiane une présence importante et
puis un visage de notre société qui est
quand même multip oui absolument c'est
un défi c'est un défi constant parce que
l'assimilation est une menace constante
et je pense que au Québec on est en
train de sonner le toxin d'une façon qui
va je pense porter des fruits à l'avenir
enfin je l'espère parce que on est à
l'abri de la simulation nulle part en
Amérique du Nord je me répète la
question n'est pas si ça va plus ou
moins
mal ou mieux que ça l'était mais
qu'est-ce que nous allons faire pour
pouvoir la préserver la promouvoir parce
que n’empêche
j'imagine que votre grande crainte c'est
que ça devienne folklorique Louisiane
LOX ça devienne quelque chose qui là
mais que dans le fond n'est plus vivant
du tout là la disparition
elle est quand même là la menace de la
dispersion elle est là pour un
francophone en Louisien je
cite Gilles Vigneau qui disait puis là
je parle la citation exacte mais pour
pouvoir préserver le français il faut
bien le parler et le lire et l'écrire et
nous avons en Louisiane pour la première
fois depuis une génération depuis fort
longtemps une communauté francophone
lettrée c'est à dire les enfants
apprennent à écrire et à lire à l'école
est-ce que ça va nous éviter la falaise
du folklore je n'en sais rien mais
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir freiner ce
mouvement ça c'est une question que les
prochaines générations vont répondre
est-ce que par ailleurs quand vous
entendez puis vous avez réagi là-dessus
par écrit quand vous avez entendu
monsieur Legault parlait de
louisianisation est-ce que quelque part
en vous ça vous énerve pas en disant là
chez nous là on fait comme vous dites
avec ce qu'on a le mieux possible
je suis
quelque part
d'accord avec ce propos là
louisianisation mais on pourrait aussi
dire la moralisation au même temps mais
j'accepte de bon cœur parce que quelque
part on a raison en disant c'est quelque
chose à éviter mais nous avons les armes
pour pouvoir l'éviter maintenant et
l'arme principal c'est
la littérature c'est de pouvoir donner à
une génération la possibilité de lire et
d'écrire en langue française ce qui nous
permet d'éviter absolument de reproches
qu'on subit mes parents que le français
était l'équivalent de l'ignorance à la
pauvreté on ne peut pas dire ça à
quelqu'un qui est lettré point ce fait
que bon c'est sûr que c'est complexe je
pense que si je reproche quelque chose à
ceux qui par de la louisianisation c'est
juste que ce n'est pas suffisamment nous
on sait par rapport à la réalité que
nous vivons à tous les jours laissez pas
simplement Lucien c'est dans toutes les
minorités dans les communautés de langue
minoritaires aucun Amérique du Nord
parce que vous l'avez souvent souligné
c'est pas la même chose est un
francophone au Québec peut-être un
francophone ou Manitoba ou en Acadie ou
en louisian ce n'est pas la même réalité
quand même
quand je suis venu ici peut-être la
première fois c'était
j'étais émerveillé par le fait qu'on
pouvait aller à la grosserie et puis
commander sa peine de lait en français
et puis on pouvait regarder la
télévision en langue française pour nous
en Louisiane on savait qu'il y avait des
Canadiens français et puis il y avait
des chemises carottées et puis du sirop
d'érable mais on n'imaginait pas moi
j'imaginais pas qu'il y avait une
société en Amérique du Nord ou on
pouvait vivre pleinement en langue
française et
quand je suis venu ici la première fois
c'était un coup de foudre et puis somme
m'impressionne toujours je dis que nous
avons vous avez quand même un grand défi
à résister l'assimilation parce que
c'est une menace qui est réelle mais en
même temps c'est quand même incroyable
que malgré tout ça on est toujours là et
comme dit mon voisin on va les embêter
encore plus longtemps
et vous comprenez avec votre cœur ce
combat-là des Québécois de préserver le
français même si en apparence on
pourrait dire qu'on sort de Montréal ça
va plutôt bien mais attention vous
comprenez cette démarche là c'est
complexe parce que il y a plusieurs il y
a plusieurs flèches dans le car quoi il
y a d'abord la culture et la culture ou
la culture musicale littéraire etc il y
a Radio-Canada il y a quand même des
grands instruments de culture présent au
Québec qui vous donne qui nous donne une
grande force en même temps il faut parce
que le mulet finalement quitté le wagon
c'est la pièce faut que l'économie de
langue française
puissent attirer des gens suffisamment
et puis l'émigration c'est un question
très très complexe faut qu'on donne aux
jeunes faut qu'on donne aux immigrants
économique aussi des raisons culturelles
pour vouloir à parler la langue
française
donc vous vous n'êtes pas découragé
l'espoir Patrice ce n'est pas
comme gagner la loterie c'est un choix
c'est un engagement je ne me permet pas
d'être décourager on ne peut pas se
permettre de décourager parce que bon il
y a toutes sortes de raisons pour le
faire mais maintenant il faut marcher à
l'avant il faut confronter les défis il
faut faire face à la réalité mais il
faut surtout avoir comme dit mon ami
Antonin maillet à voir confiance dans
l'avenir et puis faire place à la
surprise qui sera pas forcément mauvaise
vous parlez de surprise vous l'avez dit
vous êtes tombé en amour avec le Québec
milieu des années 75 j'ai vu le Québec
évolué quel regard aujourd'hui parce que
vous êtes boost très souvent ici vous
créez ici quel regard vous portez sur ce
Québec quand même beaucoup changé depuis
le milieu des années 70
franchement je suis un peu confus dans
la mesure que quand je suis arrivé ici
puis bon j'étais dans la rue prince
Arthur en 76 en train de danser en
novembre quand une élevait qu'à passer
et puis j'étais propulsé dans cette
information et puis j'étais ok on va le
faire mais en fait on n'était pas au
long de vue peu importe là je trouve que
c'est devenu un espèce de labyrinthe le
Québec c'est-à-dire entre les questions
de
d'accommodement d'immigration
d'assimilation avant c'était plus clair
c'était ok ben on veut un pays on veut
être indépendant on est pour ou contre
bon c'était plutôt clair là il y a
tellement de Nouans c'est tellement de
questions il y a tellement de de je
dirais de
pièges que moi-même je perds un peu le
nord par rapport
au Québec dans la maison que bon j'ai
passé la moitié de ma vie ici la moitié
de mon cœur est bleue avec un fleuve de
lit je suis vraiment très solidaire du
peuple québécois mais quelque part je me
demande qu'est-ce que vous êtes
qu'est-ce que nous sommes en train de
faire ça vous rend perplexe il y a des
débats ici sur l'identité sur
l'immigration qui vous rend perplexe
ça vous inquiète
non j'ai pas trop d'inquiétude
mais j'aimerais bien que
que la lanterne soit plus brillante que
que la citadelle sur lequel on se dirige
soit plus évident ce que vous dites à
quelle Richard si vous savez pas très
bien où le nationalisme québécois
s'envole moi je pense que le Québécois
le savent pas non plus c'est ça c'est ça
c'est pas moi c'est vous il y a une
certaine brouillard qui s'est installées
depuis les 40 ans que je traîne ma
brouette ici et puis
[Musique]
oui ça me l'aspect
ce n'est pas à moi de vous dire quoi
faire bien sûr je ne suis pas je ne suis
ni canadien ni québécois donc je vote
pas je paye des taxes mais ça c'est tout
est notre question
mais je suis de tout cœur donc ce n'est
pas vraiment très rationnellement mon
affaire c'est plutôt là et puis je serai
fier
de pouvoir
assister à la réalisation
de une nation qui s'assume pleinement
parlez-moi de la relation entre les
communautés francophones et le Québec ça
a toujours été
ça a toujours été soit tendu soit moins
tendu dépendant des périodes là on est
on est où aujourd'hui d'après vous
généraux des années 70 ou le
la souveraineté du Québec était vraiment
la question principale et puis il y
avait mes amis Acadiens qui paniquaient
parce qu'il pensait que un Québec
souverain eux les Acadiens ou les
franco-manitobains ou les Français
squats où j'en passe allait être
abandonné
dans un Canada très majoritairement
anglophone donc il y a toujours eu
ce problème mais là comme la question de
souveraineté semble s'estomper
le il y a plus de gorilles dans la pièce
je pense que un Québécois ne comprendra
jamais ce que c'est de vivre en milieu
minoritaire d'avoir être obligé de
parler anglais et puis je parle de la
luzienne en particulier parce que tout
ce qui est institutionnel
la politique la médecine le droit
là il y a pas de question on va on est
obligé de parler en anglais donc il y a
une certaine je dirais pas cette tenue
humiliation mais un compromis à faire
avec sa propre identité qui est
difficile et je j'applaudis et
j'encourage les Acadiens les Francs
communitobain les franco-entériens qui
sont engagés dans cette lutte sans cesse
parce que ça n'allait pas et puis c'est
quand même très encourageant de faire
partie de une communauté de résistant
parce que c'est ça de parler français en
Amérique du Nord y compris au Québec
c'est un acte de résistance
[Musique]
50 ans de carrière 22 albums et si pour
moi une seule chanson de fait définir
l'homme sa sensibilité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa force et son talent musical c'est la
balade de Jean batailleur sur son album
le plus accompli car enragé en 1996 vous
avez des chansons extraordinaires à que
Richard la ballade de Jean batailleur
par exemple si vous avez pris combien de
temps que ça oh je me souviens très très
bien c'était sur la place Berry à
l'Auberge des gouverneurs je revenais de
du premier Congrès mondial acadien en 94
donc ça faisait 8 ans j'avais pas mis
les pieds au Canada et puis mon héritage
est venu me saisir pas la nuque puis me
traînait de l'autre côté de la culture
je lance un appel au secours de la part
des Acadiens la Louisiane on a tombé de
la falaise
mais on n'a pas encore touché la terre
[Musique]
de retour à Montréal je pense que
j'étais en train de prendre une
bière blanche pour la première fois dans
la rue Ontario et puis dans mon
ivresse
joyeuse j'ai monté dans ma chambre à
l'auberge du gouverneur et puis Jean
batailleur est sorti comme ça
vous dites mais je viens de il y a une
référence quand même parce que je viens
d'un pays de batailleur on a une grande
c'est la tendance auto destructrice que
nous avons tous à l'intérieur donc c'est
une espèce de combat entre le mal et le
bien dans sa propre coeur
une situation de déracinement complète
comment comment
il y a plus rien
[Musique]
de votre vie c'est le français quand
même là même si vous dites ça c'est fait
de façon naturelle c'est un combat c'est
un engagement mais là c'est ajouter
on a plus de terre si on a plus c'est
des changements climatiques c'est le
climat c'est le ça a été Catrina dans le
cas ça c'est votre autre c'est ce qui
vous choque il y a deux choses qui votre
autre moteur ça j'ai l'impression
mon combat Patrice est plutôt d'être
bien
le reste j'ai pas choisi tout ça mais
moi j'aime des choses et puis je pense
que c'est normal quand on aime de
vouloir protéger j'aime la culture
française en Amérique du Nord j'aime
l'environnement naturel partout au monde
surtout parce que j'y viens de la
Louisiane
et quand on voit des choses menacées je
pense que c'est une réaction très très
humaine et très très normale de vouloir
les protéger je pense pas que j'ai fait
aucun effort extraordinaire je sais ce
que je fais pour la protection la
promotion la langue française ou la
protection de l'environnement naturel ce
sont des choses qui sont naturelles il y
en a d'autres qui ont fait tellement
plus que moi
qui continue à faire plus que moi et
j'ai des idoles dans ces domaines mais
moi je suis fier de faire ma part et
puis d'aider à améliorer le monde et
puis dans l'espoir de léguer au prochain
génération non simplement un meilleur
moment mais un monde tout court donc
mais oui mais pour être bien il faut
faire des choix aussi vous avez fait le
des choix vous auriez pu acquérir
Richard travaillant en anglais presque
exclusivement vous avez fait ce choix là
pour être bien prête en accord avec vos
racines avec vous-même très bien mais ça
reste un engagement parce que c'est plus
compliqué quand même là encore je suis
mon coeur c'est pas vraiment un choix je
suis mon cœur et puis c'est là que mon
cœur m'a emmener puis c'était ça ma
mission et puis je suis chanceux d'avoir
cette mission là parce que je parle
l'impression qu'on est une multitude
mais j'ai été élevé dans une famille
ou le service la communauté était très
important et mon père c'est ça qui le
motivait et puis c'était il va rester
toujours mon plus grand idole c'est
celui qui m'a montré que pour être bien
il faut donner
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose je peux pas faire
chaque jour comment je vis en demande
quoi moi
je dis que je vis sur l'amour et
j'espère que vous vieux à 72 ans il
n'est pas vieux mais cette auteur
compositeur qu'on aime vit assurément
sur l'amour en ce sens il a gagné son
pari celui d'être bien ceux de
[Musique]
au bout de la nuit
bravo Zacharie Charles merci beaucoup de
votre générosité merci bonne suite bonne
suite de concert
soyez heureux c'est ça